hello everyone we're glad you've joined
us for this webinar ion mobility mass
spectrometry in the omics
I am the shell action of laberd's and
I'll be your moderator for today's event
Thanks educational web seminar is
presented by labyrinth and brought to
you by Agilent to learn more about our
sponsor please visit
www.gfi.com/webmonitor the drop down box
located on the far left of your screen
labeled ask the question and click send
to enlarge the slide window click on the
arrows at the top right hand corner of
the presentation window if you
experience technical problems seeing or
hearing the presentation just click on
the support tab down at the top right of
the presentation window or report your
problem by typing it into the ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen this is an educational
webinar and thus offers free continuing
education credits please click on the
continuing education credits tab located
at the top right of the presentation
window and follow the process to obtain
your credit
now presented a speaker dr. Christian
art the assistant professor of chemistry
in the department of biomedical and
chemical engineering and Sciences at the
Florida Institute of Technology to learn
more about our speaker please click on
the speaker tab found at the top right
of your screen Chris you may now begin
your presentation
thank you very much for the introduction
Michelle and I'd also like to start off
by thanking Agilent for sponsoring this
event today what I'm going to be talking
to you about is a tandem technique
that's being used increasingly in
analytical chemistry and that is the ion
mobility mass spectrometry now many of
you may be familiar with the technique
of mass spectrometry but you might not
know as much about aya mobility and so
what I'd like to teach you today is some
of the ways that we can use this tandem
technique to improve our analyses in the
omics of proteomics genomics and
metabolomics
now I am mobility spectrometry although
it is a fairly emerging technique in the
biological sciences it's actually a
technique that's been around since the
1950s and it's been used for several
decades primarily in defense purposes in
fact if you can recall the last time
that you went to an airport and had your
luggage or your hand swab and then
analyzed that instrument was actually an
ion mobility spectrometer now without a
mass spectrometer on the back end but
this has been used in other applications
like customs houses and ports to test
for illicit chemicals and even has been
used in battlefield monitoring and so
how does AI a mobility work well like
mass spectrometry it does allow us to
separate gas phase ions as they move
through some sort of an external field
now with the mass spectrometer we
typically use an electric field although
we do have instrumentation that also
uses magnetic fields and an ion mobility
it's no different we use an electric
field to propel ions through some sort
of drift region now in its original form
it's still one of the most commonly used
types of ion mobility we have what's
called a constant field or drift tube
device and I've included a diagram here
where we can actually see that the ions
move through this set of electrodes here
with a drift gas in place and as these
ions move through under the influence of
the electric field they under build
collisions with this drift gas such that
smaller ions move more quickly than
larger ions now there are several other
flavors of ion mobility if you will that
have been developed over the last couple
of decades including one example which
is called field asymmetric ion mobility
spectrometry or fames this is also
commonly known as differential mobility
spectrometry or DMS and in this
particular situation we're actually
applying the electrical field in a
perpendicular way compared with the path
of the ions through here
in another more recent Advent we have
what's called a traveling wave which is
rather than a constant electric field
it's actually a dynamic field where
moving waves within the mobility so we
actually propel the ions through and
those ions that are larger and less
mobile will roll back over the waves and
they'll arrive at the detector at a
later time
now as I said within drift tube ion
mobility the simplest form we have iron
post into the drift tube under the
influence of a constant electric field
and as they move through they achieve a
constant drift velocity and are able to
be separated based on differences in
their size shape and charge smaller ions
experience fewer collisions and travel
at higher velocity now I'm here in
Florida and for any of you that have
traveled to Florida in the summer you
know that it rains every afternoon and I
like to use that as an opportunity to
teach my students about the difference
between mass spectrometry and ion
mobility spectrometry imagine that
you're walking along campus of course
with your umbrella and it starts to rain
now you put your umbrella up and you
notice that as you start to walk the
umbrella seems to have a little bit of a
restrictive force on you and that is
quite literally a drag as the gas
molecules in the air are colliding with
the large open structure of the umbrella
but when you close that umbrella it
becomes more compact you don't have
those similar collisions and you're able
to walk a little bit faster
now if I were to ask you the difference
in mass between these two things the
closed and open umbrella your response
would be well the mass is the same and
that's exactly what a mass spectrometer
gives you is the ability to very
accurately measure the mass of that
theoretical umbrella
whereas with ion mobility we can
actually tell the difference in
structure and be able to determine
whether that umbrella is open or closed
based on how quickly it moves through a
drift cell
so what we're actually measuring here is
drift time or the amount of time that it
takes for our ions to interact with the
detector such as a mass spectrometer and
we can measure this drift velocity in
terms of the length of the separation
and the drift time that we measure here
we also use a characteristic mobility
factor that we call K here which we
calculate based on that drift velocity
as well as the magnitude of the electric
field that's used in the separation
device and finally we typically refer to
this in terms of a K knot or a reduced
mobility factor which just takes into
account the temperature and the pressure
of our separations now this is an
important point to note because just
like there are many different kinds of
mass spectrometers that can be operated
under a wide range of experimental
parameters we have ion mobility
instrumentation that will go from low
pressure somewhere in the range of 1 to
4 tour all the way up to atmospheric
pressure similarly we have ion mobility
spectrometer that will operate anywhere
from ambient temperature all the way
down through cryogenic temperatures
now for those of you who like myself are
very visually oriented I've borrowed
this slide from Erin Baker at NC State
University to show a visual
representation of how ions with slightly
different structure can actually have
considerably different mobilities and
here what we have in is an example of a
couple of fatty acids and you'll notice
in this diagram on the left them they
each have one unsaturation one double
Bock but one of them is in the sis
configuration and the other is in the
trans configuration now it doesn't take
any chemistry any background in
chemistry to look at these two molecules
and say well structurally they do look
different and indeed when we pulse them
through a mobility drift so they'll
travel at very different velocities
ultimately arriving at the detector at
different times and this allows us to
create a drift time spectrum where they
are separated based on those differences
in mobility now many of you may be very
familiar with other kinds of common
analytical techniques such as
chromatography and/or mass spectrometry
well one of the ideal things about using
ion mobility is that it actually pairs
very well on a time scale with both of
those techniques that I just mentioned
we like to refer to this as nesting now
it's chromatography we're often thinking
about separation times on the order of
several minutes to even a few hours
depending on the complexity of the
sample so here I have a representative
liquid chromatography curve here that's
taking place over the course of about 10
minutes now with ion mobility we're
actually able to acquire data on the
order of milliseconds up to tens to lo
hundreds of milliseconds and what that
means is that for every single LC peak
that elutes we are able to get several
ion mobility spectrometry we're most
commonly doing this with a
time-of-flight mass spectrometer and
that's because the time of acquisition
for this kind of instrumentation is so
short we're often acquiring full mass
spectra on the order of about a hundred
microseconds and what this allows us to
do similarly is for every point across
an ion mobility
we are able to get a full mass spectrum
and determine what masses are
contributing to those ion mobility Peaks
now what this allows us to do similarly
to the way that we can combine LC with
MS and even tandem ms allows for
significant improvements in
signal-to-noise ratio and I've included
a figure from a Graham cook's article
that was actually back in the 1980s but
still holds true and that's as we
include as we increased the number of
stages of analysis going from something
like LC or GC to a combination of lc-ms
LC ms/ms and now potentially LC with ion
mobility and tandem aspect we increase
the number of stages thereby reducing
our chemical noise considerably although
also slightly reducing our signal but
because of that difference in the
decrease between those two we see an
accompanying increase in signal-to-noise
you
now again when we couple that to it to
some kind of a mass spectrometer we see
that similar to my previous visual
representation as we pulse ions through
a drift tube they're separated by
differences in their size shape and
charge and then ultimately as they
approach a time-of-flight mass
spectrometer they're analyzed and they
produce a mass spectrum now we can then
create these three-dimensional plots of
drift time versus mastercharge and so we
can get both sets of information our ion
mobility drift time and our
mass-to-charge value in one experiment
now if we are to couple this with
something like tandem mass spect we're
actually able to do this in a global or
untargeted fashion whereby we are not
isolating any ions in the quadrupole
we're actually just fragmenting those in
the collision cell many of you will be
familiar with this it's termed all ion
fragmentation
now one of the drawbacks to this
technique typically is that we're unable
to make a good comparison between parent
and fragment ions
however because our ion mobility
separation is occurring prior to this
fragmentation what we actually see is
that all fragment ions from a given
precursor will show up on that exact
same drift timeline that you see here
and that allows us to easily make these
matches between precursor and fragment
ions
so what are some of the other advantages
to using ion mobility as an analytical
technique well because we're getting
this additional mode of separation we
can take complex mixtures and
potentially be able to get more
information and separate compounds that
otherwise might Co Aleut chromatographic
Li or might appear at the same the same
mass in a mass spectrum and so here we
have a representative LC retention time
plot and we will get one of these Peaks
this first one for example we see that
the mass spectrum seems to indicate just
one compound there at a mass to charge
of 807 but when we look a little bit
closer into the ion mobility spectrum
for that peak we actually see that these
are two different compounds and these
represent isomers structurally very
similar these are actually stereo
isomers that look exactly the same in
both the chromatography and the mass
spectrometry domains but i-n mobility
gives us the ability to resolve this
now with mass spectrometry we have a
master charge value and with
chromatography we have a retention time
anion mobility what we like to refer to
is collision cross section and this can
be useful for identification because it
allows us to measure these values for
known compounds and start to populate
libraries exactly the same way as we do
with LC or GCMs libraries in this case
now the way that we get this value is
based on a drift time and a number of
other experimental parameters that are
shown here things that include the
analyte charge state the drift tube
temperature and pressure as well as the
length of the separation but when we get
these values we can then use them to
have improved confidence in identifying
these later time
so what does collision cross-section
allow us to do well when we make these
databases of mass-to-charge and
retention time we can also throw in
collision cross-section and see how that
improves our identification now we see
at the top moving along from left to
right as we start to add vias collision
cross-sections in for each metabolic
feature we can match not just based on
master chards but also in a combination
of the two and that allows us to
significantly reduce our false positive
rate because we're identifying based on
an additional metric this is essentially
four dimensional data where we have a
liquid chromatography or gas
chromatography retention time we have an
ion mobility drift time and then we have
a single stage and tandem mass spectrum
what this allows us is increased
identification consonant so that we can
actually get better information not just
on a chemical composition from high-res
accurate mass mass spectrometry but also
an actual molecule based on our
collision cross-sections
now because ion mobility is a structure
based separation technique it allows us
to get some structural information this
is a really huge part of the power of
ion mobility is the ability to look at
things like binding strength for
complexes as well as size and shape in
fact when I am mobility was first
coupled with mass spectrometry back in
the 1990s this was one of the earliest
applications was in looking at bio
macromolecules specifically proteins and
how various changes to things like
protein primary structure or different
kinds of conditions could change the
overall structure or the folding and
you're probably thinking well this
sounds a lot like what might happen in
some kind of neurodegenerative disease
where we have these actually miss
folding and indeed this has been used
for decades to study the progression of
those diseases and how those proteins
are actually folding and unfolding
but let's turn back to the omics at
large and the study of the omics is
actually several several centuries old
and what this means is we're able to
look at the relationship between several
different ohms within the human body
moving from the genes which we call the
genome going from genomics down through
RNA or the transcriptome through
proteins the proteome and finally down
to small molecule metabolites or
metabolomics and this metabolize the
phenotype which is what we actually see
in the human body and I particularly
like this slide because it also shows
how differences in things like our
microbiome as well as environmental
exposure or what we sometimes call the
expose ohm can also affect the phenotype
now looking at things like metabolomics
which is closest to the phenotype we see
that this goes back to ancient times
where actually people would look at
things like urine samples and test not
only the taste and the smell as well as
the color so believe it or not people
would actually taste urine and use a
wheel like this to try to figure out
what kind of disease a sick patient
might have now fortunately for us we
have very complex analytical methods now
so we no longer have to taste our
samples
now one of the cool things about AI in
mobility and it being a structure based
separation technique is that when we
start to plot collision cross-sections
for various biomolecules relative to
their master charge we start to see
these characteristic plots here and what
we can see on the right is that things
like lipids in green will have very
different a very different trendline
than things like peptides in blue or
carbohydrates in yellow
so as we identify some kind of an
unknown biomolecule based on both its
collision cross-section and its mass to
charge these characteristic trend lines
can actually give us more information on
what kind of molecule that is so let's
jump into some examples of actual data
and look at a few different biomolecular
classes and how I am ability has been
used both in my lab as well as in other
labs to improve upon those analyses
so my lab does a lot of research with
the analysis of steroids and here we
have the synthetic pathway that produces
a low pregnenolone from the precursor
cholesterol and we see a couple of
molecules highlighted here pregnant
alone and five alpha D hydro
progesterone and if you can see from
looking at these two molecules these are
actually structural isomers
so again they'll look exactly the same
in a single stage mass spectrum and they
can be challenging to separate using
chromatography but here in just under 25
milliseconds we're actually able to
resolve these and measure collision
cross-sections that differ considerably
at approximately 176 and 191 angstrom
squared respectively
we've used this for a number of
different steroid isomer pairs going
from some biologically important
compounds like 17 hydroxy progesterone
and 11 deoxy quarter cortisol shown up
in the left corner and corticosteroid
and eleven deoxy cortisol shown in the
top-right corner down through some
compounds that are also used in
development and doping purposes like
testosterone and epi testosterone as
well as structural isomers and roast our
own and trans and roast our own in the
bottom right hand corner
now I mentioned that I a mobility is a
separation technique that involves ions
colliding with buffer gas molecule but I
should spend a little bit more time
talking about what that buffer gas is
historically people have most often used
helium as the buffer desk because it
most it most closely resembles a small
hard sphere now because of a lot of
practical considerations namely the
price and the lack of availability of
helium people have progressed to using
nitrogen is a more common buffer gas
molecule but this is one example of an
experimental variable that we can change
to try to tailor our experiment to
better separations and so here I have an
example where we're looking at three
different isomers testosterone and its
structural isomer dehydroepiandrosterone
as well as its epimer epi testosterone
and we can see that although
testosterone is well separated from its
two isomers those two compounds are
almost completely overlapping in the ion
mobility domain with nitrogen gas
however if we were to switch over to
something else like a larger more
polarizable drift gas in this particular
case we're using carbon dioxide we can
see that these compounds now have
different interactions with the buffer
gas molecule and those differences allow
us to start to resolve these compounds
now we've seen this similar kind of
analysis with other kinds of
biomolecules these are steroid
derivatives bio acids and we see that
with very similar chemistry here the
bottom two examples glyco keno
deoxycholic acid and glyco works there
so deoxycholic acid the only difference
is in the stereo configuration of a
hydroxyl group in the topcase glyco
deoxycholic acid we actually have that
hydroxyl group in a different position
on the C ring instead and what we can
see here is using ultra-high-resolution
ion mobility we're able to resolve these
fairly well
let's move on to a different kind of
biomolecule in the case of glycans now
glide cams are a really interesting
class here because they have so much
differences in their structural in the
structural diversity of these compounds
we have different sugar monomer isomers
we have different kinds of linkage and
we also have things like differences in
1 6 vs 1 4 and even alpha beta linkages
shown here now these are a very
challenging class for mass spectrometry
based separations and certainly a
challenging class for chromatography but
what we can see is differences in these
linkages for example allow us as shown
here on the right hand side these can be
separated using ion mobility
now I mentioned that we can get some
kind of confirmation or ordering or
these trend lines within an ion mobility
drift time versus mass plot we also see
a couple of other examples where this
can be seen for charged state as well I
told you that I in mobility is a
separation based on size shape and
charge and what we see is that ions of
similar mass but higher charge will
travel at a much faster mobility time
than we see with those that I have the
lower charge and what that allows us to
do is separate all of these into
characteristic trend lines we can also
separate things based on differences in
the lengths of some of their functional
groups here we have tetra alkyl ammonium
salts that go all the way from a3 that's
a propyl group all the way up through a
16 carbon chain and these you can see
increase not just in mass but also in
their eye on mobility drift time
now moving on to fatty acids and lipids
which are another great example of a
structurally diverse class here we're
going to expand upon that example that I
showed you before with two fatty acids
differing in the configuration
this forces trends of their double bond
here we actually have an 18 : 1 fatty
acid meaning that we've got 18 carbons
in the chain with 1 unsaturation well is
that 4 different examples here two of
them with the carbon double bond at the
9 position and the other two at the 11
position and for each of those we've got
that double bond in the Syst forces the
trans configuration and these are then
compared with the completely saturated
18 : 0 fatty acid and what we see here
in these bottom left two figures is that
we're actually able to get good ion
mobility resolution between these based
on differences in the position of the
double bond double bond position as well
as the configuration being cysts or
trends
now we can also look at building upon
fatty acids and moving into lipids with
lipids we have an additional way that
these can differ in their structure and
that's the difference between where the
connectivity of those fatty acyl tails
is on the head we can have those in the
sn1 or sn2 position or we can take those
tails and switch them here on the left
hand example we have two fatty acyl
tails one with 16 carbons and no on
saturations and the other with 18 carbon
and no on saturations and we see in that
blue versus black representation where
the position of those is change relative
to sn1 and sn2 that they actually have
slightly different mobilities we can
also have differences in their SN
backbone attachment as you can see here
relative to that that's Austral
phosphate moieties there where we have
those actual fatty acyl tails can change
the mobility quite a bit
now we've already mentioned the
difference between cysts and trans
orientation but here we have another
example this is a phosphatidyl
ethanolamine a PE with 18 carbons on
each chain and one double bond and
either the this configuration shown at
the top or the trans configuration shown
at the bottom and what we see here is
that these actually differ again in
their iron mobility we can also have
stereochemical differences this one on
the on the right is an example of two
sera mids where the hydroxyl is either
in the alpha or beta position on that
tail and we can see that again this
changes their mobility quite a bit
let's jump into another example of a
small molecule another biomolecule and
this is vitamin D metabolites and this
is a really important case of two
structural isomers that are often well
they're they're often confused with one
another they're present in much
different populations of humans from
infants to Pediatrics and even adult
populations but there's a couple of
issues between these two different
isomers one of them has a much higher
calcium regulation that's the 25 hydroxy
vitamin d3 shown at the top right and
the bottom one has a reduced calcium
regulation there has also been also been
shown to be linked to potentially other
diseases now in this case because
they're isomers and because many LC
methods do not differentiate them we
actually can get some kind of bias in
our measurements when we're really
wanting to quantitate just 25 hydroxy
vitamin d3 we can get a positive bias
based on the presence of this epimer
shown here so as I hope you're thinking
by now well if they're structurally
different till we potentially resolve
them using ion mobility
well when we look at these compounds in
the most common ion that we would
analyze we're looking at the N plus h
with a water loss and mass-to-charge 383
and unfortunately as you can see from
the ion mobility spectrum here they are
nearly overlapping we don't get great
separation here but this is a great
opportunity for me to introduce another
way that we can improve upon ion
mobility resolution when we talk about
mass spectrometry we're always talking
about the analysis of ions now these
might be protonated or deprotonated ions
or might add on something else like a
sodium ion a phosphate ion or
potentially something else like an
alkali metal
now why does that matter for ion
mobility with what the mass spectrum
what we'll see is simply a difference in
the mass potentially better separation
in chromatography or potentially an
improvement in the signal intensity
within the mass spectrum with ion
mobility when we start to look at
different ions such as in this case
Saudi ated ions we start to see an
improvement in their resolution so here
I would like to show an hi in mobility
plot that includes 25 hydroxy d3 as well
as its epimer and I've included 25
hydroxy vitamin d2 this is the plant
derived source of this molecule and what
we see here is that well the resolution
is slightly better but still not great
but being good analytical chemists we
wanted to look into the data a little
bit more and what we found interestingly
enough was that 25 hydroxy vitamin d3
also has this unique drift peak out here
at around 30 milliseconds now
interestingly enough this same peak is
not seen for the epimer and it's also
seen at a much later drift time
indicating that it's a much larger
structure but what is that well in
trying to figure out exactly what that
compound was with a considerably larger
cross section we wanted to turn first to
our mass spectra and make sure that what
we were looking at was indeed the same
compound or some kind of isomer here and
what we found was that in addition to
this drift peak that we have here at 30
milliseconds we also have a couple of
longer drift Peaks out between 35 and 40
milliseconds now thankfully mass
spectrometry allows us to answer one of
those questions those Peaks out at sea
are actually divers that we can see at
mass-to-charge 823 but the mass spectra
between a and B look nearly identical so
what is that new compound that we're
identifying at a later drift time
well we're going to turn to theoretical
modeling and this is a powerful
combination often used with ion mobility
to get a better sense for what kind of
structural differences are really
contributing to some potential
separations now when we think about ions
in mass spec we're really just making
sure that we can indeed ionize compounds
to begin with and so if we add something
like a sodium ion and we see that in our
mass spectra we're pretty happy and we
don't necessarily think about the actual
physical placement of that sodium ion
within the molecule but what we see is
25 hydroxy vitamin d3 is essentially a
hydrocarbon say for the presence of a
hydroxyl group at each end of the
molecule and so when we add that sodium
ion in with its positive charge it's
most likely going to interact with one
or the other hydroxyl group based on the
partial negative on the oxygen atom but
there's also another potential
opportunity here and that is that based
on the structural flexibility of this
molecule we can actually have this
wraparound such that both hydroxyl
groups are interacting with the sodium
ion simultaneously and what we see here
is when we actually do theoretical
modeling to calculate the lowest energy
conformation of these molecules we see
that indeed they do adopt this closed
low-energy conformation and the
agreement between our theoretical
collision cross-section our experimental
collision cross-section is quite good
however what we also find is that
there's another local minimum another
potentially accessible structure here in
open conformation in which that sodium
ion interacts with only one of the
hydroxyl groups now if we actually plot
out all of our putative structures from
our theoretical modeling and plot them
against the difference in those two
different structures that the closed
conformation versus the open
conformation we see that for Hydrox is
at 25 hydroxy vitamin d3 the difference
in energy is quite small meaning that
both of those confirmations could be
adopted however when we look at the same
kind of energy diagram for our our
epimer we see that that energy diagram
is considerably larger
that open conformation is actually not
energetically accessible and so this
peak that appears here labeled B is our
open conformation of 25 hydroxy vitamin
d3 that allows us to resolve these two
compounds when otherwise we might not be
able to
so let's move into one last example of
the omics moving from very small
molecule metabolites up to very large
molecules like proteomics and the way
that I and mobility can be used to
improve upon that now I've shown an
example of a protein hear retinol
binding protein 1 and if we were to
analyze that using mass spectrometry our
approaches would largely fall into two
different categories the first is what
we would call top-down proteomics this
is the analysis of impact or native
proteins and it can be very challenging
experimentally it generally requires
very high resolution mass spec and a lot
of expertise in this kind of field but
historically easy easier way and the
more commonly used way to identify
proteins is to use what's called
bottom-up proteomics and what this means
is that we actually cleave these
proteins using something like a trypsin
digest and we cut this up into smaller
peptides that we can then analyze using
anything ranging from a very high
resolution mass spectrometer even to a
triple quad instrument for targeted
applications and because this has a less
of an instrumental burden it's a more
common method but where can I in
mobility fit in for this well let's take
an example of a peptide that I've shown
here the mass the charge of 9.99 and
I've highlighted two different serine
residues and that's because Furion is a
common location where we can see a post
translational modification or a PTM
called phosphorylation and we can
potentially phosphorylate either of
those two serine residues now imagine if
we have a mixture of those two different
peptides
or to try to separate them using even
ultra high pressure liquid
chromatography we would see that they
unfortunately are coalition because
there are also isomers we can't
differentiate between them using mass
spectrometry either but when we analyze
that mixture using ultra high-resolution
ion mobility we show here that we have
an arrival time distribution with two
different Peaks not quite baseline
results but good enough to tell the
difference between these two and when we
then run those two compounds as
individual standards we can actually see
that we are able to separate these
isomers based on the placement of that
sauce for relation group whether it's
that syrian towards the the end terminus
or whether it's at that serine in the
middle of that peptide
now when we use this to look at
something like a global protein dry it
digest we're able to get an increased
number of features that we can identify
because we're now taking and separating
in three different dimensions first our
chromatographic retention time and our
ion mobility drift time and lastly our
mass spectrometry mass-to-charge value
and we can see here this cool plot where
we're actually showing the number of
features that are identified in three
dimensions
now one final thing that I want to talk
about is some of the ways that we can
use ion mobility with other cool
innovations to actually get some more
information about impact proteins and
here we have a method that's called
collision induced unfolding what this
allows us to do is take native proteins
that are in their most common folded
state and subject them to increased
energy now as these proteins increase in
energy we'll actually get a gas phase
unfolding of these changing not their
Maps but changing their structure and
when this structure changes we'll see
that as a corresponding increase in
drift time we can then plot that
collision voltage the energy that we're
giving to these proteins as are
unfolding relative to their drift time
so that we can see these characteristic
unfolding events and this tells us a lot
about the dynamics of the protein
folding as well as the overall structure
of those proteins
now there are a lot of new directions in
ion mobility analysis and this is really
where we're moving to improve the way
that we use this in the omics one
particular example is things like higher
resolution instrumentation we've vendors
have introduced things like trapped ion
mobility as well as a more recent Advent
structures for lossless ion
manipulations slim in which we're
actually able to get considerable
increases in resolution between
structurally similar compounds now one
of the things that we'd like to look for
in the future is being able to couple
ion mobility with higher resolution mass
spectrometers not just time-of-flight
instruments this might be things like
orbit Ray's orbit trap based platforms
or potentially even FTA CRM platforms
we'd like to see more continuity in
measurements and calibration as well as
population of CCF databases across the
wide range of vendor options as well as
the different flavors of ion mobility
that I mentioned very early on to be
able to take something with a static
field a constant drift tube based
measurement and compare that CCS to
something like a traveling based
measurement that that's a very powerful
continuity there finally we'd like to be
able to expand upon using other tandem
techniques tandem ms with all iron
fragmentation even looking at things
like spectroscopic techniques where
there's work going on with coupling of
ion mobility with UV and/or IR
spectroscopy as well as being able to do
some gas phase chemistry like ion ion
and iron molecule reactions finally we'd
like to look at some ways that I a
mobility can improve upon some of our
commonly used sampling techniques these
include things like mass spectrometric
imaging as well as ambient ionization
including things like desorption or desi
electrospray ionisation potentially
other analytical areas we'd love to hear
about other ways that I a mobility might
be able to improve upon your analyses
because the well there are since there's
no limit on the kinds of applications
that this could be used for
so finally I'd like to finish by
acknowledging some of my past and
current co-workers including those
listed here at the University of Florida
those listed here at Pacific Northwest
National Lab dr. Aaron Baker as well as
my group here at Florida Institute of
Technology including my graduate student
Aurora burkas Matosevic and several
other students in my group listed here
and with that I'd like to again thank
adjoint for sponsoring this and at this
point I would be happy to take any
questions that you might have
thank you Chris for your presentation a
quick reminder for our audience on how
to submit questions simply type them
into the drop down box located on the
far left of the presentation window
labeled ask a question and click on the
send button
Christel answers many questions as we
have time for our right first question
is what are some of the major
instrumentation advances that can be
expected
well I think I hit upon that a little
bit in my last slide and I think really
what this is is kind of a two-fold
approach one is taking ion mobility to
higher resolution so that when we have
compounds that are very very similar in
collision cross-section much like a lot
of those examples I showed where we
clearly have two different peaks for two
different isomers but are not quite
baseline resolved what kind of
instrumental approaches can we take to
improve upon that and it's it's really a
matter of how high can we get in
resolution just like we're always
pushing the the boundaries of how high
we can go with resolving power and mass
spectrometry we look to do the same
thing with developing higher resolution
ion mobility techniques and like I said
there are a few notable examples of that
that are being developed both
commercially and also in research labs
such as the structures for lossless ion
mobile manipulations platform that's
being developed at Pacific Northwest
National Lab and I think that's going to
really allow us to get better
separations than we can with more
historic instrumentation the second
thing that I would say in terms of
instrumental advances is coupling this
with techniques that allow us to get a
little bit better information about our
molecules and this could be things like
other kinds of fragmentation methods in
addition to just collision induced
dissociation I'm talking about things
like electron based methods electron
capture Association and electron
transfer dissociation as well as some
light based methods like UV photo
dissociation and infrared multiple photo
dissociation all of these that give us a
little bit more information about the
molecules to help us and identify
differences in those molecules that are
separated with ion mobility
you
okay next question how can resolution be
improved in the case of diastereomers or
even enantiomers
that's a good question I think that's
really one of that that illustrates one
of the major advantages to using ion
mobility is for things like isomers
so with diastereomers when we have some
differences in the stereochemistry
we're largely able to separate a lot of
these and I've shown a number of
examples of them throughout the
presentation now in order to make those
kind of separations better I think that
goes back to the first question that I
answered which is in our ability to get
higher resolution measurements so that
very very subtle structural differences
between things like diastereomers and
epimers can still be resolved with this
now enantiomers are kind of an
interesting problem because enantiomers
or mirror images are essentially at the
exact same collision cross-section and
by themselves cannot be resolved with
ion mobility however we've published a
number of cases in which we can separate
those mostly by interacting them with
some other kind of molecule that has
chiral structure to it so we can get
these complexes where two different
enantiomers will interact with a chiral
molecule and can thus be separated using
ion mobility and I think that's really
the only way that it can be done
although it's important to note that
these approaches are far from universal
and can be technically very challenging
to develop so enantiomers are still
really what one might consider the holy
grail of ion mobility separations but
they can be done
once again thank Chris for his
presentation I'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today any
questions we do not have time for today
we'll be addressed by the speaker via
the contact information you provided at
the time of registration we would like
to thank laberd's and our sponsor
Agilent for underwriting today's
educational webcast laberd's will alert
you via email when it's available for
replay we encourage you to share that
email with your colleagues you may have
missed today's event until next time
goodbye